this is mark billy billingham he served
in the british sas for over 17 years has
been responsible for planning and
executing strategic operations across
the world is a certified
counter-terrorism instructor has led
countless hostage rescues as well as
much more today he's joining us to break
down modern warfare 2019's iconic sas
clean house mission you know having been
part of some of this stuff that that to
me felt really good really really
realistic we've got a few more videos
with mark planned taking him through
many more of the call of duty sas
missions across the franchise so be sure
to subscribe for that and if you want to
see more of billy billingham you can
check out the links to all of his
socials as well as where to buy his new
book survive to fight in the description
below right over to billy
sergeant garrick thanks for your intel
we'll track the alcatile cell
responsible for the piccadilly attack to
a townhouse in north london
three sas teams will get inside and
connect the dots
if the wolf is in possession of the
stolen russian gas in kyrgyzstan we need
to find it the scenario is great the
setup you know something happening in a
faraway land that's going to have a
massive impact on something and then
related back to a situation that led to
the initial intel like the the bomb
there going off in london and linking
people if you look back at the london
bombings that's kind of how it all
started and linked to things that the
network opened up all around the globe
you know nobody expected it to be as big
as it was and this is basically so the
scenario is basically what i'm saying is
pretty good pretty realistic
be advised
there may be non-combatants on target
check your shots
verbal there was
say you know there will be unarmed
civilians involved it goes without
saying but it does get sad you know we
just remind ourselves that although it's
aggressive
it's still sensitive
let's kick this off
well this bit here i did pick on this
before
the first man who's opening the gate
he's concentrating on the gate the guy
to his right shouldn't be watching him
open the lock he should be looking
forward you know but that's very minor
detail but other than that it's good a
little bit punched but it's good
okay so it's a simultaneous attack we've
got verbal and visual comms which is
good you know and you're doing a
simultaneous attack so the first thing
you want to do is as you're breaching
okay it's it's very controlled as well
on the communications
alpha one's in position bravo wants
everybody's into one position we're all
outside the building all call signs
stand by and move so now everybody's
moving so now i'm expected to see
somebody come down the alleyway because
although he's moving forward he looks
down the alleyway and it tells you
somebody else is moved to that position
you get that but that would be more
control because i could have been
anybody to be honest you know when you
look you've seen somebody he's out the
guy's moving is that the enemy
so just a very minor point but just so
much bear in mind
okay um
you know you probably get a scream out
of it over that door and seeing somebody
but he's on it pretty quick so we'll
give them the benefit of that
trust the world you know i do
but this operation fails so why are we
done
make sure
he identified the guy at the end of the
table is obviously i'm assuming you know
you divided pictures of your what you
call your x-rays if you're terrorists so
i've identified it but the thing with
that is
in law call today he'd be lucky why did
he shoot him why didn't you detain him
you could say his hands are not seen he
could have a weapon he could have you
know that might be a good reason for
that person at the front to make that
decision and that's his decision
but looking at that there you know you
don't see a weapon friend what should
have possibly might have got in he's
just gone in
give him a quick challenge without
trying to you know create too much of a
fuss there is a weapon on the table
which the guy to the left went for so
that's fair game they are bearing on
intelligence though you know they may be
using their ieds you know initiation
packet under the table next to which
kind of just grabs or that justifies the
existence of what you're doing so just
bear that in mind but otherwise yeah
it's good movement entering through the
front door
yeah it's good visual visual
communication checking where everybody
is
yeah movement's good you got you've got
the back ears coming to the right
they're all covering different angles
nobody moves around like this they just
don't because you tunnel vision you're
bumping into as you are the weapons are
here and although it's a state of eye
readiness there are people against them
you still because you can actually fire
from there bang bang bang bang and then
come up into the air if you really need
to
see the thing with this now for me is
there's been a number of shootings
people screaming and showing so this is
now what is called gun noisy you know
we're still moving pretty tactically
which is fair enough but
it's kind of noisy people are screaming
shouting there'd be like lights on
everywhere probably
and for us it's probably now best
right your eye our goals are use the
light there's women screaming and
shouting don't shoot this at the other
so the whole house is alive however
let's stay with the stealth thing
because that's what we've got here the
movement's good the target indication is
good and it's aim shots it's not
automatic and craziness the other bits
of pieces you've got there is obviously
what you don't see on this which is fair
enough is as you take a room and you've
clearly if there's bodies in there or
people in there then you've got to leave
people behind to contain it
make sure
that's a bit wild
first they're just blasting behind the
door like that probably wouldn't happen
because again there might be kids in
there might be civilians you've got a
collateral damage you've got to think
about
bravo six move into the
moving on
again i mean you systematically clean
the building this is the thing with this
stuff when you do this you literally
have to clear every it takes time so
when it go when it go you want it to go
noisy as soon as the first round has
gone down it's got noisy that's it we're
on it's on let's go bang bang bang and
you've got to clear everything from the
toilet it could be all to
for like whatever reason they went past
that door there i don't know why it
looks like they were going to leak that
hole past him and some reason he walked
past it then he got a few rounds through
the door which he hit one of the um so
we've got a casualty now and then you
can't go to automatic fire through a
door because again and we've had this
you know i've gone into a target exactly
that rounds are coming through the door
you've got to still suppress the fire
make sure you can see what you're you're
aiming at so basically what you probably
do there is just hold it outside the
door from the flashing create that
distraction door opening and in
see what you're shooting you can't just
go shooting blind because inevitably
what you will have is and we've had it
i've had this kids lined up in there
rolled up in carpets you know so enter
is it again you can't just go throw in
the hd explosive i explosive grenades
collateral damage is key there will be
kids in there there's already women in
there as you see so
as opposed to they should have stacked
on that door cleared that room moved on
they didn't clear the room the wall
passed it paid the price took a casualty
and like i said the drills there have to
become the same control aggressive but
fast and you've got to identify target
you can't just fire blind
okay yeah you look like he's popping him
with a weapon the first one was shot on
the way in okay fair deals good move
bedroom clear
get those rooms cleared
it's even more clear what i said earlier
on there it's gone really noisy now just
get those lights on get that [ __ ] on you
can move a lot quicker
casualty there what we do have
is you know we'll have our own patrol
medics
we're all you know patrol medic to a
degree but on most of the race that we
did in places where we did rip these
raids without the medic would be with us
he'd be at the back so as you've already
said rooney bottom floor was clear so
he'd be
be there while you cleaned the first
floor he'd be outside as soon as that
first falls clear he'd be coming in so
if there is casualties he can go deal
with it you know i mean because you
can't afford to leave manpower beyond
that's 25 you you fire power gone and
your team it breaks up the teams you got
to keep the teams together as best you
can so that medic would deal with that
as quick as possible if like it is there
to be fair that floor's not clear yet
you'd have to hold on the floor get the
medic in and then move on again
moving on to the third floor now so two
floors secured
the movement's great
the crossing over arcs keep it visual
with each other is good the weapon
outlet and movement is good it's
realistic it's not this up in the eyes
you know channel
okay right so again i'm just watching
this here obviously as i alluded to
earlier when you've got people
casualties and um
non-casualties you have to leave people
behind to contain them and which he did
there the guy stayed with the woman and
the kid got him suppressed but then this
guy here moving on it does happen i
ain't going to say it don't happen it
doesn't because you have to move quickly
just have to take that risk but ideally
you won't move into that room until
somebody's on your shoulder there's two
of us okay as you get the shoulder with
you let's go but moving through and
going down the corridor he's flashbanged
another room and he's gone in he's gone
on his own it's a general rule we
wouldn't do that we shouldn't do that i
ain't saying we don't do it so we can
call this this is pretty realistic
but in the in the best scenario is on
your shoulder okay so you get whacked
you can continue that fight because if
you're on your own out there i'm now
watching these children and looking for
anybody else in that room my back's
really turned if he's been shot the guys
come back into this room then you're
you've got two casualties it's minor
stuff but it's fixed but there is
realism there definitely realism because
it does happen you know
it's all great to have these this is how
it should happen but and the reality
when you call the light of day when
you're in there it all goes peaked on
the rounds are going it's gone noisy
things do change so it is realistic
again he's moving on night vision
goggles the fact that you come into that
room that there's light on there you get
blinded you like
it just it just burns out just for a few
seconds or
or a bit longer so the thing is they
just you flip that thing up and just
keep going because you can't afford to
stand there messing around so bang flick
it rather than try and shoot out the
light
i'll give you the benefit of the doubt
you get your shots out of the light
that's fine
[Music]
fair game i mean that's good that was
really good actually because i mean you
know you've come in you you've
of course she's frying she's scared
however she's been given direction told
to stand still or get down wherever
she's been told
and she's bolted there's a reason why
she's bolted i mean you've got to make
that decision yourself why have you just
done that she became she could be going
for a weapon she could have a weapon she
could have a best one
there's a lot of the targets you're up
against now you know suicide bombers
there's already been noise in the house
she's definitely already been alerted
i'd imagine so
tensions are high
i didn't see a weapon but we'll see then
we're going to kill come on he stops me
in here
clear
all teams turn out secure commence sse
roger good terminology there you know
all floors are secure move to ssc ssc
means collect all evidence
this is now where if you're identifying
the bodies completely you were taking
all the information required for the
hard drives
any weapons any equipment anything
that's visual that you think
documentation that's been collected now
for evidence you're going you're really
into the forensic side of it and that's
a quick process so it does have to
happen quick so that's pretty good and
pretty realistic from what i remember
she was going for bloody detonator
good job we dropped it in we made the
right call sir i'm about euros
we've got a location on a wolf
overall actually i think it was very
realistic
few monopods and it's easy to pick
little minor things you know some of the
the the movement was good the
equipment's good i'm looking at what
they're carrying now they're carrying it
their movement is good the way they move
the cell the communication visual verbal
communication paramount without it it
goes to ratchet there's good visual and
verbal communication all the way through
the relaying the talking you can see
them looking at each other crossing over
arcs making sure the weapons are
covering so that's all good it's really
good
the tactics are pretty good the only
things i've picked up is moving on your
own going noisy early once it goes noisy
rounds are going down i don't care how
cold where you think you are so we could
have gone noisy a bit early when i went
by going noisy it's then down to
screaming and shouting to each other
aggressive movement
light as much light as you need you need
the light you know it's great working in
all this sort of stuff you can take it
that maybe there's no power in the
buildings because some of these don't
have so then you're staying as you are
but in that case it was and the scenario
was great real good scenario makes sense
based on a lot of obviously a good
intelligence you've been given there for
that
and that's very realistic to the modern
day sort of counter-terrorist global war
against terrorism that we're up against
and you know having been part of some of
this stuff that that to me felt really
good really really realistic and to be
fair again
there are mistakes being made it should
be because we make mistakes as i said to
you
we try to move in pairs all the time
sometimes you get a little bit carried
away and you're off on your own and you
get away with it sometimes you might not
overall really really good i'm not a
games person that's just got me into it
it's got me hooked a little bit
i'm about your house huge thanks to
billy billingham for joining us on this
video if you enjoyed make sure to hit
the like button and subscribe as we've
more on the way and of course be sure to
check out billy's new book or the links
to which will be in the description
below thanks for watching
[Music]